virtually every rich person I know
started off not as a rich person even my
family and the assumption is because I'm
an orthodox Jew and because I went to
Harvard that I must have like tremendous
family wealth or something I grew up in
the same bedroom as my three younger
sisters with one bathroom for six people
until I was 11 years old that doesn't
make me poor but certainly would make me
Rich look at the people who are rich and
then ask them how they got to be that
way and that's the question that nobody
wants to ask is how do the rich people
get to be rich not do you have sympathy
for the person who's poor I have such
sympathy for people who are poor that I
want them to be rich